Congratulations, you just finished your first lesson. Following the lesson is
going to be a problem set, where you answer questions based on what you've
learned so far. Now, this is going to be the format for every lesson to come.
&gt;&gt; So if you're ready, go back to the problem set for lesson one and answer each
question. If you get stuck, go back to the lesson. Or, to the forum, where you
can then interact with your peers or with us.
&gt;&gt; After you finish a problem set for lesson one, you're ready to move on to
lesson two. Where we're going to look at how psychologists conduct experiments
to learn more about human thought and behavior. Now it's important for the
remainder of the course that you notes while you're watching the lessons. In
addition, be sure to check the instructor's note section, which is here, to get
other valuable information that's contained in each lesson. And we'll see you
in lesson 2.